coria está organizando un concierto de
música planea invertir dos mil pesos
para alquilar el lugar y pagarle a los
músicos y lo hago vender los boletos a
20 pesos cada uno la gráfica de abajo
muestra la ganancia jay que obtendría el
concierto como una función de los
boletos vendidos x esta gráfica de aquí
luego nos dicen si cores decidiera
vender los boletos a 40 pesos cada uno
cuál sería la nueva gráfica de la
ganancia y nos piden arrastrar los dos
puntos para mover la recta a la posición
correcta
ok pensemos en esto si core y vendiera
ningún boleto si no vendiera boletos en
absoluto entonces aún así tiene que
pagarle a los músicos y tiene que
alquilar el lugar así que perdería dos
mil pesos estarían menos dos mil es lo
mismo que sucede en esta gráfica de acá
ahora si vendiera diez boletos vende
diez boletos a 40 pesos cada uno
eso significa que gana de los boletos
400 pesos pero tuvo que pagar 2000 de
cualquier modo así que en realidad su
ganancia sería de menos 2400 que sería
menos 1600 sigue sin ganar dinero si
vendiera 20 boletos 20 por 40 son 800
así que tendría que ganar menos 2000 que
son los que tienen que pagar más 800 que
ahora sería 1200 mil 200 si vendiera 30
entonces ganaría 1200 pesos pero aún así
tiene que pagar 2000 así que la gráfica
quedaría aquí
pueden usted notar que esta línea en
realidad es la gráfica si vendiera 50
boletos a 40 pesos obtendría 2 mil pesos
de los boletos pero tuvo que gastar 2
mil para pagar las cosas así que ahí
saldría equilibrado y no ganaría ni
perdería dinero
si para encontrar yo vendiera 60 boletos
60 por 40 son 2400 así que gana 2400 de
los boletos menos los 2 mil pesos que
tuvo que pagar por el alquiler y para
pagarle a los músicos obtendría 400
pesos de ganancia así que esta es la
gráfica correcta veamos
muy bien